>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
SO DID YOU MAKE A MOMENT FROM
YOUR BUSY LIFE TO TURN ON THE
HEARINGS ON CAPITOL HILL TODAY
WITH THE SILICON VALLEY CEOs?
DON’T BE EMBARRASSED IF YOU
DIDN’T.
YOU PROBABLY DIDN’T.
NO MATTER HOW WORRIED YOU ARE
ABOUT BIG TECH AND OBVIOUSLY YOU
SHOULD BE GRAVELY CONCERNED, YOU
MAY HAVE DECIDED TO SKIP TODAY’S
SPECTACLE AND FOLD THE LAUNDRY
OR CALL YOUR IN-LAW’S INSTEAD
AND WE DON’T JUDGE YOU FOR THAT
PREVIOUS HEARINGS ON BIG TECH
HAVE NOT PRODUCED A LOT.
ELDERLY SENATORS WHO CAN’T
MANAGE TO SEND THEIR OWN TEXT
MESSAGES WAGGING THEIR FINGERS
IN THE FACE OF SNEERING
BILLIONAIRE OLIGARCHS IN SAN
FRANCISCO ALL OF WHOM SEEM TO
UNDERSTAND THAT NO MATTER WHAT
HAPPENS INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM
THEY WILL GET TO CONTINUE DOING
WHATEVER THEY WANT TO DO BECAUSE
THEY HAVE GOT ALL THE MONEY.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT A NUMBER OF
TIMES IT.
SEEMS POINTLESS.
IN FACT, IT SEEMS INSULTING TO
THE REST OF US.
IN THE END TODAY’S HEARING MAY
PROVE JUST AS POINTLESS.
WE WILL FIND OUT.
FOR ONE BRIEF MOMENT TODAY YOU
GOT THE FEELING THAT MAYBE
ACTUAL PROGRESS WAS BEING MADE.
MAYBE THE GOOD GUYS MIGHT NOT BE
ENTIRELY LAME.
THAT MOMENT CAME WHEN SENATOR
JOSH HAWLEY ASKED MARK
ZUCKERBERG, THE CEO OF FACEBOOK,
ABOUT AN INTERNAL TOOL THAT HIS
COMPANY HAS DEVELOPED CALLED
SENTRA.
HAWLEY KNEW ABOUT SENTRA BECAUSE
A WHISTLEBLOWER TOLD HIM HOW IT
WORKS.
FACEBOOK EMPLOYEES USED SENTRA
TO SPY ON USERS EVEN WHEN THOSE
USERS ARE NOT USING FACEBOOK.
SENTRA GIVES FACEBOOK ACCESS TO
TROVES OF PERSONAL DATA
INCLUDING THE PAGES USERS VISIT
AND THE ACCOUNTS THEY HAVE
LINKED TO FACEBOOK.
YOU DIDN’T KNOW ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE ALL OF IT HAPPENS IN
SECRET.
IT’S PROBABLY NOT EVEN LEGAL.
SO TODAY AT THE HEARINGS JOSH
HAWLEY CONFRONTED MARK
ZUCKERBERG ABOUT THIS AND HERE’S
HOW IT WENT.
>> SENTRA IS A TOOL THAT
FACEBOOK USES TO TRACK ITS USERS
NOT JUST ON FACEBOOK BUT ACROSS
THE ENTIRE INTERNET.
SENTRA TACKS DIFFERENT PROFILES.
THEIR MESSAGE RECIPIENTS, THE
LINKED ACCOUNTS THE PAGES THEY
VISIT AROUND THE WEB.
MR. ZUCKERBERG HOW MANY PAGES
HAVE BEEN VISITED AND SHUT DOWN
THROUGH SENTRA.
>> SENATOR, I DO NOT KNOW
BECAUSE I’M NOT ACTUALLY
FAMILIAR WITH THE NAME OF THAT
TOOL.
I’M SURE THAT WE HAVE TOOLS THAT
HELP US WITH OUR PLATFORM AND
COMMUNITY INTEGRITY WORK.
BUT I AM NOT FAMILIAR WITH THAT
NAME.
>> DO YOU HAVE A TOOL THAT DOES
EXACTLY WHAT I DESCRIBED AND
THAT YOU CAN SEE HERE OVER MY
SHOULDER OR ARE YOU SAYING THAT
THAT DOESN’T EXIST?
>> SENATOR, I’M SAYING THAT I’M
NOT FAMILIAR WITH IT.
>> Tucker: I’M NOT FAMILIAR WITH
IT, SENATOR.
BUT, HOLD ON A SECOND, MARK
ZUCKERBERG.
YOU RUN THE COMPANY.
YOU STARTED IT.
AND SENTRA SOUNDS IS UNLIKE A
PRETTY BIG DEAL.
ARE YOU SAYING THAT SENTRA
DOESN’T EXIST?
WELL, NO.
IT TURNS OUT THAT’S NOT WHAT
THEY ARE SAYING.
JUST HOURS AGO A FACEBOOK
SPOKESPERSON ADMITTED TO FOX
NEWS THAT SENTRA IS INDEED REAL.
AND ACCORDING TO THAT
SPOKESPERSON SEBAALI THAT IS
USED TO QUOTE CENTRALIZED AND
AID IN INVESTIGATIONS INTO
COMPLEX SUBJECTS IS UNLIKE
COORDINATED INAUTHENTIC
BEHAVIOR.
END QUOTE.
COORDINATED INAUTHENTIC
BEHAVIOR, HARD TO PRONOUNCE.
YOU MAY NOT HAVE HEARD OF IT.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
ASTROTURFINGING THE FAKE
GRASSROOTS POLITICAL MOVEMENTS
SOMETIMES BY FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS.
SOMETHING THE LEFT CLAIMS TO BE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT.
IN OTHER WORDS, SENTRA IS YET
ANOTHER LONG TERM CONSEQUENCE OF
THE RUSSIA HOAX.
SO ADAM SCHIFF GETS HYSTERICAL
ABOUT VLADIMIR PUTIN AND THEN
FACEBOOK GETS TO SPY ON YOU
WITHOUT YOUR KNOWLEDGE AND THEN
SELL THE DATA THEY GATHER.
PERFECT.
BUT SOMEHOW MARK ZUCKERBERG WHO
RUNS THE COMPANY SAID HE HAD NO
IDEA IT WAS GOING ON.
AND SENTRA WASN’T THE ONLY
SECRET INTERNAL DATA GATHERING
TOOL THAT ZUCKERBERG CLAIMED TO
BE EGG NORNTED OF.
SENATOR HAWLEY ALSO ASKED HIM
ABOUT ANOTHER INTERNAL FACEBOOK
PROGRAM CALLED TASKS.
ACCORDING TO SENATOR HAWLEY’S
WHISTLEBLOWERS, TASKS ALLOWS
FACEBOOK’S CENSORSHIP TEAMS TO
QUOTE COMMUNICATE WITH
COUNTERPARTS AT TWITTER AND
GOOGLE AND ENTER THOSE COMPANY’S
SUGGESTIONS FOR CENSORSHIP ONTO
THE TASK PLATFORM SO THAT
FACEBOOK CAN THEN FOLLOW UP WITH
THEM AND EFFECTIVELY COORDINATE
THEIR CENSORSHIP EFFORTS.
GOT THAT?
THEY ARE ALL IN IT TOGETHER.
THE TECH COMPANIES AMOUNT TO A
CENSORSHIP CARTEL.
MARK ZUCKERBERG DID NOT DENY
THIS.
INSTEAD HE CONCEDED IT WOULD BE,
QUOTE:  PROBABLY PRETTY NORMAL
FOR PEOPLE TO TALK TO THEIR
PEERS IN THE INDUSTRY.
AND SO, YES, IT IS ALL REAL.
SILICON VALLEY ACTS AS ONE.
THE TECH OLIGARCHS JOINED FORCES
TO CENSOR THEIR POLITICAL
OPPONENT.
YOU MAY BE ONE OF THEM.
YOU AREN’T BEING PARANOID TO
WORRY ABOUT THIS YOU WERE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
IS THE HAIR ON YOUR ARM STANDING
UP YET?
CHRIS COONS ISN’T WORRIED.
HE WAS THRILLED TO HEAR IT.
HE WANTS MORE.
COONS IS A SENATOR FROM
DELAWARE.
FORMER JOE BIDEN STAFFER
ACTUALLY.
THE DESCRIBES CHRIS COONS AS
MODERATE NOT BECAUSE OF WHAT HE
SAYS BUT BECAUSE OF YOU WHO HE
SAYS IT.
CHRIS COONS IS BORING, THEREFORE
HE MUST BE REASONABLE.
THAT’S THE THINKING.
BUT IN FACT CHRIS COONS IS NOT
REASONABLE.
IS HE A POWER HUNGRY LUNATIC WHO
DOESN’T BELIEVE IN THE FIRST
AMENDMENT.
OF COURSE CHRIS COONS WENT TO
YALE LAW SCHOOL.
NOTICE HOW NO ONE EVER WENT TO
YALE LAW SCHOOL ACKNOWLEDGES THE
BILL OF RIGHTS?
WHAT’S THAT CONSTITUTIONAL LAW
CLASS IS UNLIKE AT YALE LAW
SCHOOL?
WE SHOULD FIND OUT.
WATCH CHRIS COONS PUSH MARK
ZUCKERBERG IN THE HEARINGS TODAY
FOR EVEN MORE CENSORSHIP
ACCORDING TO CHRIS COONS THERE
IS NOT ENOUGH.
>> DO YOU, MR. DORSEY, HAVE
POLICIES AGAINST DEEP FAKES OR
MANIPULATED MEDIA AGAINST
COVID-19 MISINFORMATION, AGAINST
THINGS THAT VIOLATE CIVIC
INTEGRITY BUT YOU DON’T HAVE A
STAND ALONE CLIMATE CHANGE
MISINFORMATION POLICY.
WHY NOT?
HELPING TO TO DISSEMINATE CLIMAT
DENIALISM IN MY VIEW FURTHER
FACILITATES AND ACCELERATES ONE
OF THE GREATEST EXISTENTIAL
THREATS TO OUR WORLD.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS TO JACK
DORSEY WHO RUNS TWITTER.
CHRIS COONS’ POINT IS SIMPLE
PEOPLE WHO DISAGREE WITH CHRIS
COONS ARE QUOTE AN EXISTENTIAL
THREAT TO OUR WORLD.
THEY MUST BE SILENCED.
SO WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE THAT
CHRIS COONS DOESN’T BELIEVE
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO SPEAK IN
PUBLIC?
WELL, PLENTY OF THEM WOULD BE
CREDENTIALED SCIENTISTS WHO
MIGHT HAVE LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS
ABOUT CHRIS COONS’ GLOBAL
WARMING THEORIES?
CHRIS COONS IS A LAWYER WHO
SPENT THE LAST 20 YEARS IN
GOVERNMENT.
EVERYTHING HE NOSES ABOUT
CLIMATE HE LEARNED FROM AN ISSUE
OF THE ATLANTIC MAGAZINE HE
PICKED UP AT THE AIRPORT NEWS
STAND.
CHRIS COONS IS A NONEXPERT IF
THERE EVER WAS ONE.
UNDER THE STANDARD HE IS
DEMANDING AND DEMANDED TODAY IN
CONGRESS THE SOCIAL MEDIA
MONOPOLIES WOULD CENSOR ANYONE
WHO QUESTIONS HIS SHALLOW SILLY
VIEWS ON ONE OF THE MOST COMPLEX
AREAS OF KNOWN SCIENCE.
THAT IS NOT A MODERATE POSITION.
IT IS AUTHORITARIANISM.
AND THERE IS A HUGE COST TO THE
REST OF US.
THIS IS CENSORSHIP.
CENSORSHIP DOESN’T SIMPLY KILL
EXPRESSION, THOUGH IT DOES.
CENSORSHIP KILLS THINKING AND
INNOVATION AND WISDOM.
CENSORSHIPLEADS TO
SELF-CENSORSHIP.
PEOPLE QUICKLY LEARN WHAT
THEY’RE ALLOWED TO EXPRESS AND
WHAT THEY ARE ALLOWED TO
BELIEVE.
SO THEY STOP ASKING QUESTIONS
EVEN OF THEMSELVES.
THEIR MINDS BECOME NARROWER.
THEY STOP CREATING.
ART DENIES.
SCIENCE WHICH DEPENDS ON FREE
INQUIRY BECOMES IMPOSSIBLE.
DOES THAT SOUND FAMILIAR TO YOU?
IT’S WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
THAT’S NOT A PROBLEM FOR PEOPLE
IS UNLIKE CHRIS COONS.
HIS MAIN CONCERN IS HOW TO
CONTROL AN INQUISITIVE
POPULATION.
COONS WOULD BE DELIGHTED FOR A
COUNTRY THAT CANNOT THINK FOR
ITSELF A NATION OF PASSIVE
CONSUMERS THAT TAKES ITS ORDERS
FROM TECH OLIGARCHS SHUT UP AND
OBEY OR WE WILL MAKE YOU BE
QUIET.
THAT’S THE MESSAGE THEY ARE
SENDING, COLLECTIVELY.
A LOT OF US EXPECTED SOMETHING
DIFFERENT TO HAPPEN.
THE ELECTION IS OVER.
THE BILLIONAIRE PARTY GOT WHAT
IT WANTED.
SO WHY CAN’T THEY TAKE THE BOOT
OFF OUR NECK?
NO CHANCE.
THEY ARE JUST GETTING STARTED.
AND IN THE PAST TWO WEEKS
CORPORATE AMERICA HAS RUSHED TO
CONSOLIDATE ITS CONTROL OVER
INFORMATION AND DISSENT IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WE COULD GIVE YOU COUNTLESS
EXAMPLES OF THAT HERE ARE A FEW.
THE EMAIL DELIVERY SERVICE MAIL
CHIMP ANNOUNCED IT IS REFUSING
TO PROVIDE SERVICE EMAIL TO THE
NORTHERN VIRGINIA TEA PARTY.
WHY?
THE COMPANY SITES POTENTIAL
MISINFORMATION.
TURNS 00 THE TEA PARTY HAD
ATTEMPTED TO NOTIFY ITS MEMBERS
ABOUT A RECOUNT RALLY BY EMAIL.
THAT’S NOT ALLOWED ANYMORE.
MAIL CHIMP BANNED THEM ALONG
WITH OTHER CONCERN
ORGANIZATIONS.
THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED TO USE
EMAIL.
PAYPAL AND AIR B BNB TAKING.
THE MESSAGE THEY ARE SEND
SOMETHING REALLY SIMPLE.
IF YOU WANT TO LIVE A NORMAL
LIFE HERE, SEND AN EMAIL,
TRANSFER MONEY, RENT AN
APARTMENT, YOU HAD BETTER BE ON
THE RIGHT SIDE.
HOW IS THAT DIFFERENT FROM WHAT
HAPPENS IN CHINA?
CALL US AND LET’S US KNOW IF YOU
CAN SPOT THE DIFFERENCE.
WE’LL CAN’T.
ABIGAIL SCHRIER WHO WE TALKED
ABOUT YESTERDAY ON THE SHOW GOT
AN UNEXPECTED PH.D. IN POLITICAL
REPRESSION.
AMAZON CUT OFF SALES HUGE SPIKE
IN TRANSGENDER IN TEENAGE GIRLS
REAL THING WANTED TO KNOW WHAT
WAS HAPPENING.
TRIED TO EXPLAIN IT NOT ALOUD.
TARGET BANNED HER BOOK
COMPLETELY FOR TIME A LAWYER AT
THE ACLU WHICH OF COURSE USED TO
DEFEND CIVIL LIBERTIES CHEERED
THAT DECISION AND SAID THE BOOK
SHOULD BE BURNED.
MEANWHILE IN A STORY VERY FEW
SAW, A MAJOR VIDEO GAME COMPANY,
ERASED A VOICE ACTOR NAMED HELEN
LEWIS FROM ONE OF ITS TITLES
RETROACTIVELY.
ERASED HER FROM THE PICTURE AS
THE SOVIETS ONCE DID WHAT WAS
HER CRIME WROTE A FORUM POST
THAT MANY ON THE INTERNET
THOUGHT WAS TRANSPHOBIC.
FOR THAT UBISOFT THOUGHT SHE
SHOULD NEVER WORK AGAIN
ANYWHERE.
EVEN HER VOICE WAS TOO OFFENSIVE
FOR THE REST OF US TO HEAR.
THE MOB THEN WENT TO WORK TRYING
TO DESTROY GINA AN ACTRESS TO
PLAY AS CHARACTER AMANDA LORIAN.
WHEN SHE CRITICIZED MASK
MANDATES AND QUOTE PREFERRED
PRONOUNCE THEY DECIDED SHE
NEEDED TO BE FIRED.
WHERE IS THIS COMING FROM?
ALMOST NOBODY IS UNLIKES IT.
ALMOST NO AMERICAN SUPPORTS IT.
CORPORATIONS ARE BEHIND IT.
ALL OF IT.
AND THE POINT IS NOT TO HELP
ANYONE MUCH LESS YOU.
LET’S BE CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
THE POINT IS TO ESTABLISH
CONTROL.
THEY KNOW THAT THEY CAN DICTATE
WHAT YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO SAY
ABOUT TRANS RIGHTS OR MASK
MANDATES.
THEY CAN DICTATE WHAT YOU CAN
SAY ABOUT ANYTHING.
THAT’S UNPRECEDENTED POWER.
NO ONE IN THIS COUNTRY HAS EVER
HAD THAT POWER.
OUR CONSTITUTION USED TO PREVENT
IT.
BUT THEY HAVE IT NOW.
AND THAT POWER WILL COME IN
HANDY WHEN THEY ARE RUNNING THE
GOVERNMENT WHICH THEY MAY SOON
BE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE PEOPLE JOE
BIDEN WANTS TO INSTALL IN THE
WHITE HOUSE IN JANUARY.
SO FAR BIDEN HAS HIRED A FARMER
PHARMACEUTICAL AND INSURANCE
INDUSTRY LOBBYIST CALLED STEVE
TO BE HIS CHIEF COUNSELOR.
A VENTURE CAPITAL EXECUTIVE WITH
CLOSE TIES TO BIG TECH RON
KAYLEIGH McENANY TO BE DEPUTY
CHIEF OF STAFF.
JED O’MALLEY DILLON CO-FOUNDED
CONSULTING COMPANY THAT
REPRESENTED BIG PHARMA.
BIDEN ALSO, WE LEARNED TODAY, IS
BRINGING ON LOUISIANA LAWMAKER
CEDRIC RICHMOND.
RICHMOND HAS BEEN A RELIABLE
ALLY OF THE FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY
WHICH BY THE WAY IS QUITE
POLITICAL THESE DAYS AND NOT
CONSERVATIVE.
TIME TO UPDATE YOUR PERCEPTIONS
ON THAT.
RICHMOND HAS RECEIVED MORE MONEY
FROM THE OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY
THAN VIRTUALLY ANYONE ELSE IN
CONGRESS.
SO CORPORATIONS ARE GETTING MORE
CONTROL.
AND ONCE THEY RUN EVERYTHING,
THEY WILL CONTROL WHAT YOU SAY.
WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE THE
POLITICIANS AND THE CAREER
BUREAUCRATS?
WELL IT LEAVES THEM FREE TO PAY
THE ROLE OF PETTY TYRANT
SOMETHING THEY HAVE ALWAYS
WANTED FULFILLING THEIR PERSONAL
DESIRES TO IMPOSE THEIR WILL ON
THE REST OF US.
IN THE STATE OF MICHIGAN THE
POOR PEOPLE WHO LIVED THERE
LEARNED GOVERNOR WHITMER
RELISHES TELLING HER
CONSTITUENTS WHETHER THEY CAN
HOLD THANKSGIVING DINNER AND IF
THEY DO, SHE SAID, ON SUNDAY,
THEY ARE ESSENTIALLY KILLING
PEOPLE.
>> IF YOU ARE CONSIDERING
SPENDING THANKSGIVING WITH
PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF YOUR
HOUSEHOLD, I URGE YOU TO
RECONSIDER.
AND I HATE TO SAY IT.
BUT WE KNOW THAT SOME PEOPLE
WILL GATHER ANYWAY.
AND ODDS ARE THAT SOME OF THESE
GATHERINGS WILL SPREAD COVID AND
CONTRIBUTE TO THE LOSS OF LOVED
ONES.
>> Tucker: I HATE TO SAY THIS
THERE IS THE FALSEST PHRASE EVER
I HATE TO SAY IT.
SHE DOESN’T HATE TO SAY IT.
SHE HAS BEEN SAYING IT ALL YEAR.
IN APRIL, GOVERNOR WHITMER
BANNED THE SALE OF PAINT AND
FURNITURE.
WHAT SCIENTIST TOLD HER TO DO
THAT?
NONE.
SHE DID IT BECAUSE SHE COULD.
NOW SHE IS BANNING THANKSGIVING.
WHAT NEXT?
AND THAT’S NOT A RHETORICAL
QUESTION BY THE WAY.
THIS IS MORE THAN A SLIPPERY
SLOPE WE ARE WATCHING IT HAPPEN
IN REALTIME.
AT A PRESS CONFERENCE YESTERDAY
THE GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA GAVIN
NEWSOM EMPHASIZED THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING HERE YOU NEED TO
STAY ISOLATED.
HE DOESN’T.
GAVIN NEWSOM WENT TO A PRIVATE
BIRTHDAY PARTY WITH A DOZEN
PEOPLE FRENCH LAUNDRY IN NAPA.
TURNS OUT HE WASN’T BREAKING THE
RULES WHEN HE DID THAT KNOW
WASN’T.
SETTLE DOWN.
HE WAS GIVING YOU AN EXAMPLE OF
WHAT NOT TO DO.
GAVIN NEWSOM WAS RISKING HIS
LIFE FOR YOU.
HE IS A COVID MARTYR.
WHY DOESN’T ANYONE APPRECIATE
GAVIN NEWSOM?
BUT, AGAIN, THAT’S IMMATERIAL.
WE WANT TO RESTATE HERE THE
IMPORTANT THING, THE ESSENCE OF
SCIENCE, REALLY IS THAT YOU
SPEND THE HOLIDAYS ALONE.
>> I WILL REMIND YOU THAT THREE
PRONGED APPROACH PREVACCINE WAS
AROUND PREVENTION, TESTING AND
ISOLATION.
ISOLATION, THIS IS PROFOUNDLY
IMPORTANT, PREVENTION IS ONE
THING.
TESTING WHAT’S THE PURPOSE OF
TESTING BESIDES OBVIOUSLY
IDENTIFYING PEOPLE?
THAT ARE POSITIVE AND BUILDING A
FRAMEWORK AND PROTOCOL TO
PROTECT THEIR HEALTH BUT ALSO
PROTECT OTHERS THROUGH ISOLATION
AND QUARANTINE.
>> Tucker: THERE IS A LOT COMING
AT US NOW.
TAKE THREE STEPS BACK, PAUSE,
ASK YOURSELF WHAT ARE WE REALLY
WATCHING?
WE ARE WATCHING SOMETHING PRETTY
DARK HONESTLY.
THIS ISN’T THE POLITICS WE HAVE
COME TO UNDERSTAND IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THIS ISN’T THE USUAL DEBATE
ABOUT TAX RATES OR TARIFF
POLICY.
WE MISS THOSE DEBATES.
THIS IS A STRUGGLE FOR THE
FUNDAMENTALS.
WILL THIS REMAIN A FREE COUNTRY?
CAN YOU DISAGREE WITH CORPORATE
AMERICA AND STILL LIVE HERE?
WILL WOULD HE BE ALLOWED TO FLY
ON AN AIRPLANE, STAY IN A HOTEL,
HAVE A CREDIT CARD, USE EMAIL
WILL TINY BRAIN NAPOLITANOS IS
UNLIKE CHRIS COONS DETERMINE
WHAT SCIENCE IS AND WHAT YOU CAN
SAY ABOUT IT OR NOT?
THAT’S WHAT’S ON THE STABLE
RIGHT NOW.
WE UNDERSTAND WE JUST HAD AN
ELECTION.
WE UNDERSTAND IT’S IN DISPUTE.
WE UNDERSTAND THERE IS A LOT OF
NEWS GOING ON AT THIS MOMENT.
BUT NOTHING MATTERS MORE THAN